for free
that's why you say you know
even about the eyes
as a gift on a condition if you're too
high
oh God because your eyes is more
valuable than anything else again
below you so don't believe Allah
blessings we have many blessings we go
to hospitals you see some people that
cannot go to the bathroom by themselves
likewise goes to the graveyard there's
people who have passed away and they
died as a disbelievers are you still
alive you still have a chance to turn
back to God you know
there's a Hadith
on the day of judgment
if
if I give you this word 10 times yeah
would you sacrifice it for the sake to
serve yourself today for the punishment
of God you will say yes Allah I will
sacrifice
for the sake of saving save myself from
the punishment Allah will say to him
I'll ask you one thing to worship me the
Lord and to associate anything as a
partner with me
and he did not do it it was too late
today to become a Muslim testify there's
no one worthy of worship Allah Muhammad
the message of Allah that is to learn
how to pray step by step you know so
if you
talking about Allah
anything stop you from becoming the
product to your creator because you know
this is a test you understand when I
start practicing it is when I start
practicing after I come out prison I
start practicing Islam there's certain
things like for example listen to music
it was hard for me to stop listening
music but I never said you know what I'm
gonna stop praying because I listen to
music let me carry on praying let me
carry Worship in Allah
knowing about my creator
but I love I love more than anyone else
more than anything else but doesn't mean
I'm not gonna listen music in the future
but if I do fall into listen to music I
see forgiveness of Allah but I will
never let nothing stop me from praying
to Allah you know because
there's something
live don't let nothing stop you you know
one of the prophecy in the Quran Allah
said
it's Allah
in order for them to prepare the other
religions even if it is Believers is
like
like you know
there's many people try you know and
mainstream India always be incredible is
that yeah however the first growing
illusion but the face of the Earth is
the step
who's doing the job a lot and guess what
Allah mentioned in the Quran 1400 years
ago
and we can see right now he's a prophecy
you know even another one show you about
Islam Prophet Muhammad was in Medina in
a place called City but he immigrated
law of Jewish people and those Jewish
people believe that Jesus was not
prophet of God he wasn't he was evil but
Prophet Muhammad if he was a liar where
he would have done he would have agreed
with the Jewish people to gain more
followers yes but what he did he said no
Jesus was a righteous man he was a pure
man his mother was a pure woman and he
was a messiah you know so he was
defending Jesus
if you do look at it from Material point
of view he's not going to gain nothing
Allah so he has to convey what Allah
understand him to defend Jesus even if
the Jewish people don't like it in that
place instead so there's a clear sign
he's very super liar because a liar why
would you you will do
it instead another one I give you why
Prophet Muhammad is a true prophet and
is an honest person
during his lifetime his breath is one of
his friends he was married to a woman
that he loved us so much yeah but that
woman she didn't want to she didn't want
to stay with me anymore all right
he was watching his threat going around
what would happen then he went to her he
said awesome
message of Allah are you commanding me
because Allah told you to have to go
back to him if it is the case then I'm
gonna obey Allah oh you just try to be
the age
what's up
that is not a trait of a liar a liar
will try to humiliate people try to
misuse people but only look at the
teacher of the Prophet Muhammad his
biography is sufficient to know this man
is a message of the most high let's jump
Allah does he make sense what I said so
far yesterday
Muslim you know we live to Christianity
what it means follow our crisis would
you look to Judaism follow us through
that Buddhism full of Buddha Islam not
full of Muhammad is let me to submit to
Allah according to the teacher Prophet
Muhammad Islam connected to your creator
submission Allah
creation
Satan would inspire people to change
what Allah's creation so Allah created
as a man that will change it to become a
woman I like it as a Woman They
said that is 1400 years ago
I feel I should have won as an armless
person even though but I believe I was
born in the wrong body I should have no
arm would you help me to come up
because it changes
instead of teachers doesn't mean because
you feel something you have to inventy
doesn't mean I feel I'm gonna kill
someone I go kill it let's say say to
play with your mind and you know there's
another Hadith
he said it will come outside when a
woman
foreign
people with death so Allah also
mentioned in
this is
Lord because the day of Resurrection is
some day of judgment Allah gave you give
you everything everything that you turn
away from it and you fall and you follow
his enemy then don't blame yourself
Islam if someone never heard about Islam
dice for the day of Resurrection alone
of partnership allowing testing first
because he never knew about Islam but if
someone knew about Islamic turns away
from it you know Allah said whoever
Allah will be planned
who is just than the one who's been
reminded with Allah's versus
foreign
[Laughter]
Jesus put your family foreign
father well his father was disbelievable
yeah his father with his believer
Abraham his father was a big worshiper
and Abraham said I guess
but Islam teach us even if your parents
are a lot of Muslims people
together
the man will run away from his wife
[Music]
broke me give me water give me a house
yes that's what I grew up
with my neighbors am I a good person I'm
not he was like my parents
issue
my wife was patient because she doesn't
know what she's my mother but Allah
choose my wife even I took care of her
about her kids now she loves me
forever
parents should not be a party of you to
become a Muslim you know because like I
said No One Is Gonna Save you in front
of Allah even your own family they will
tell the women with their Resurrection
everyone will save myself even the
prophet of God they'll be scared
it's not a joke that day is the day of
Justice the day when the True Justice
will be established the day of judgment
so you should prepare ourselves
[Music]
like you know what happened to my wife
we should become Muslims she never told
her mother she was praying inside her
room
guess what English sister becomes
and she came to us and she was complain
him which is you know make sure she has
to wake up early in the morning to pray
but guess what she has to pray in the
bathroom
foreign
is
true servant of mine is
at the opposite of that is fine because
like I said Allah is supposed just Allah
outages might create the Hellfire
outfits mercy and out of the generosity
is very Paradise
the correct path and it breaks up the
good way and the evil way but it's up to
you what you want to choose instead but
all the day of judgments for the devil's
Direction don't blame the one he said
that's why they have Resurrection
you know
puppies
they'll become a Muslim step by step
reading
hello
you repeat after me then English
which is
because yes you can share the chat okay
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
you guys know we are raising money for a
message a message which we need you need
the community needs and as you know the
situation in the Masjid is a dire one we
got rats who got bin bags we've got all
sorts of things along the pathway just
before you even reach the message and
the message as you know due to its size
cannot capacitate the amount of people
that we have in this growing Community
as you know remember
whosoever builds a muscle then Allah
will build him a house in Paradise we
want houses in Paradise but now's the
time to work Now's the Time to put the
investment in this life for the
afterlife so what we're doing about
Irfan and afterwards let's try and if we
really try to put as much as we can into
this campaign to the best of our
abilities rather fellow people
foreign
have fun
it's the last messenger